[Musique]
Charles de Courson bonsoir bonsoir nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne internet
qui s'appelle seriew nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succintement mon nom est
Charles de courourson je suis député de
la 5e circonscription de la Marne depuis
32 ans maintenant voilà et puis j'ai
d'autres mandats voilà j'ai une autre
vie avant d'être élu député voilà
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez me dire sur
les finances
françaises finances françaises sont un
dans un état de dégradation grave et on
ne redresse toujours pas contrairement
ce qui est affirmé par certains
ministres et l'absence de majorité r
encore plus compliqué le dressement des
finances publiques françaises nous
sommes maintenant le pays le plus mal
géré de toute l'Europe
is et et de loin même les Italiens parce
que en général les Italiens étai étaient
un peu derrière nous et bah ils ont bien
amélioré la situation voyz et donc on
néchappera pas si vous voulez à une
politique courageuse de redressement or
il y a deux
façons de redresser les finances
publiques c'est de faire des économies
sur la dépense et et ou d'augmenter les
recettes mais augmenter les recettes
dans un pays qui a déjà le taux de
prlement obligatoire le plus élevé
j'allais dire presque au monde de toute
l'Europe si vous voulez et et ça
continue en 2025 si vous voulez c'est
pas raisonnable ça veut pas dire qu'il
faut pas faire un certain nombre de
mesures en recette ou de redéploiement
dans le sens notamment de la justice
fiscale mais le problème de fond il est
sur la dépense si on était une
démocratie mature on mettra les
différents courants politiques autour de
la table en disant voilà la situation et
ne pas dissimuler la vérité la dure
vérité et donc voilà quelles sont les
idées d'économie et quelles sont les les
mesures sur lesquelles il y aurait au
moins une majorité voir une forte
majorité ça serait ça une démocratie
mature et là on en est loin j'entends
dissimulation et j'entends courage on
commence par dissimulation on nous a
dissimulé on nous a intoxiqué on nous a
enfumé nous la population française où
on a intoxiqué les marchés pour gagner
du temps et éviter la dégradation de la
note française oui la commission je
complète est-ce qu'on a fait de la
subordnation de vote par de la dette
alors euh non sur ce deuxème point non
puisque c'est passé entre nous à coup de
493 donc il y a pas eu de subordation
mais euh sur le fond la commission
d'enquête se termine elle rendra ses
conclusions dans qu' un jour 3 semaines
3 semaines euh disons à peu près 3
semaines et elle montrera que les
ministres qui était au courant notamment
sur la dégradation 2024 n'ont pas dès
novembre décembre hein 2024 on a toutes
toutes les preuves y compris les notes
de la direction du Trésor et de la
direction du budget en disant on dérape
complètement alors il y a eu tout un
débat au sein du gouvernement d'après ce
qu'on a réconstitué entre ceux qui
disaient il faut faire une loi de
finance rectificative une loi de finance
appéculative en février euh où il aura
fallu expliquer que ce qu'on vient de
voter euh bah n'était pas sincère quoi
voilà bien et et il y avait les
élections européennes euh en juin et
donc ils ont préféré des mesures euh non
législative c'est-à-dire pas de loi de
finance ctificative et on prend quelques
mesures sur les dépenses on annule une
dizaines de milliards par un décret
d'annulation euh on essaie de freiner la
dépense si vous voulez et puis peu à peu
bah ils ont découvert que l'ampleur
était encore plus importante que ce
qu'il craignaiit puisquon on a fini avec
des pertes de recette fiscale de l'ordre
de 41 milliards on n'a jamais vu
ça quelles vont être les sanctions ça va
être responsable mais pas coupable
encore une fois ça va être du pénal ça
va être une petite tape sur les doigts
un pompan cucu ça va être quoi alors la
commission d'enquête n'a pas de pouvoir
à caractère pénal voilà et euh c'est la
sanction c'est une sanction politique de
dire vous avez dissimulé voilà il y
aurait éventuellement sanction pénale si
certains des témoins qui viennent devant
la commission et qui prêtent serment
hein montent effrontément et qu'on
prouve que ils ont siamment menti à la
commission combien c'est comment combien
la sanction combien d'années de prison
euh ça doit être un an ou deux je crois
enfin c'est c'est un maximum comme un
petit bracelet un petit bracelet et on
reste chez soi tranquille ouais ouais
oui oui oui
et et ça n'a été fait qu'une fois à ma
connaissance dans une commission
d'enquête dont j'étais le rapporteur
nous avons saisi le pénal c'était la
première fois depuis 1958 et c'était une
affaire Air Liberté vous retrouverez
tous les documents on avait subodorer
une dizaine de milliards de
détournements on a saisi au pénal et au
pénal ils ont trouvé 12 12 13 milliards
de détournement voilà donc il a été
condamné à rembours c'est mais c'est le
pénal on n'est pas une commission
d'enquête n'a pas de pouvoirs pénaux le
seul pouvoir pénal qui a de président de
la commission d'enquête c'est si
quelqu'un refuse de venir devant la
commission c'est-à-dire le le le
problème du secrétaire général deéélysée
comment il s'appelle déjà Alexis coler
Alexis cè bon il a refusé par écrit de
venir invoquant la séparation des
pouvoirs mais on lui dit vous êtes pas
président de la République c'est
d'autant plus étrange que dans l'affaire
benala la commission d'enquête
sénatoriale il était venu il y a
d'autres membres euh du de l'entourage
du président qui sont venus devant les
commissions moi j'ai j'ai j'ai présidé
la commission d'enquête sur Jérôme
Cahusac et voilà le
problème de ce compte qu'il avait en
Suisse enfin toutes ces questions et et
on a voulu savoir qu'est-ce que ça fait
président Hollande voilà et on a appris
que son directeur adjoint cabinet avait
été approché par le maire de villeeluve
qui lui-même savait c'est lui qui avait
entendu et enregistré le fameux
discussion avec son chargé d'affairesz
et ben il est venu tout de suite il est
venu devant la commission il a expliquer
ce qui s'est passé voilà qu'il avait été
contacté que dès que il a appris ça il
est allé voir le secrétaire général de
l'élycée et avec le secrétaire général
ils sont allés voir François hande le
président de la République de l'époque
pour lui dire écz on a des remontées
nous disant que il a un compte en Suisse
on a la date on a tout voilà
donc si vous voulez le le le dans le cas
d'Alexis coller qui a refusé donc le
Président je crois que c'est la deuxième
fois de la commission d'enquête a saisi
au pénal puisque le refus de venir
devant la commission est sanctionné par
une peine maximale de 2 ans
d'environnement et 7500 € d'amende 2 ans
d'emprisonnement oui mais c'est la p
maximale et puis ça peut être avec
surcil enfin ça c'est la justice qui
mais ça va être très intéressant parce
que c'est un cas d'école et cette
décision justice fera
jurisprudence quand on reviendra sur les
les politique courageuse et toute cette
dialectique politicienne je dirais quand
est-ce qu'on va voir les cowboys du FMI
débarquer en
France bien quand les marchés financiers
comm on va dire on prête de moins en
moins à la France et à des taux de plus
en plus élevés il il y a un moment alors
là ça commence mais si vous voulez c'est
des variations de 05 06 07 points euh de
de de de taux d'intérêt alors vu les
masses si vous voulez c'est pas rien
mais la charge de la dette c'est combien
la charge de la dette les intérêts de la
dette c'est 55 milliards et le
remboursement du capital c'est 150
milliards mais ça le remboursement du
capital bah si vousz on rembourse le
capital on serait entêant c'està dire
par exemple en 2025 l'ordre de grandeur
c'est on va sur les marchés pour lever
300 milliards qui servent à rembourser
1550 milliards donc la dette dans les
prévisions budgétaires c'est une
majoration de la dette de l'État de 150
milliards en 2025 sachant qu'elle est
actuellement de 2600
700 3000 3003 non oui mais 3000
milliards c'est la dette de la sécurité
sociale de l'État et des collectivités
locales c'est la somme des trois mais là
on est à
3300 donc les cowboys du FMI quand ils
vont arriver en France qu'est-ce qui va
se passer et bien si on n pas le courage
d'assumer nos responsabilités bah ils
feront ce qu'ils ont fait dans tous les
pays en situation très grave il se
mettra autour d'une table et ils diront
bah il faut réduire bah alors on réduit
où comment on discute et et on dit il
faut faire voyez euh j'avais une note de
la direction du Trésor qui est de fin
février qui faisait le point parce qu'il
commence à cogiter sur 2026 bon eu il
disaient il faut faire à peu près 35
milliards d'économie sur le budget de
l'État budget de l'État c'est 500 allez
500 en bonne comptabilité 530 540
milliards voyez donc 35 milliards
d'économie sur le budget de l'État euh
c'est pas impossible à faire hein mais
ça suppose des décisions courageuses et
et d'autant plus difficile à prendre que
vous avez pas de
majorité vous pouvez m'expliquer ce que
c'est une décision courageuse une
décision courageuse c'est c'est
ce une décision courageuse c'est une
décision
euh euh qui entraînera une certaine
hostilité au moins d'une partie de
l'opinion public voilà toutes les
décisions sont pas applaudies dès demain
il y a des décisions qu'on pourrait
prendre
qui serait à mon avis
applaudi par les les Français je veux
dire quand par
exemple si on réduisait un
peu le crédit d'impôt sur les services à
la personne qui est le 2è poste qui
dépasse les 6 milliards voyez le premier
c'est le crédit d'impô recherche qui
dépasse les 7 milliards dans les
prévisions
2025 voyez est-ce qu'il faut continuer à
avoir un taux aussi élevé je vous donner
une illustration très
amusante sont éligibles 23 postes voyz
de service à la personne il y en a un
qui est assez amusant c'est si vous
devez faire promener votre chien ou
votre chat c'est éligible au crédit
d'impôt voyez bon c'est Epsilon c'est
pas avec ça que vous allez rresser les
finances de l'État mais voyez de se
poser les questions est-ce qu'il faut
maintenir cela est-ce qu'il faut rester
à 30% est-ce qu'il faut passer à 25 %
voyz toutes ces questions vous avez un
chien non vous avez un chat non vous
avez déjà eu un chien non vous avez déjà
eu un chat non c'est parce que j'aurais
pas le temps de m'en occuper VO je suis
tout le monde par bon et PARVEAU voilà
donc c'est pour ça je n'ai pas de chien
vous êtes le député qui a le plus
d'expérience je ne dirais pas le plus
vieux député mais celui qui a le plus
d'ancienneté combien d'années déjà 32
ans 32 ans d'anciené c'est mon 8e mandat
et à chaque fois réélu au laain ah sauf
la dernière fois où ça a été ça a été
juste hein il y avait qui en face un
candidat du Rassemblement national
comment vous expliquez la montée du
rassemblement
national dans ma circonscription ou en
France bah j'ai commencé par ma
circonscription c'est une
circonscription très rurale les gens en
ont marre c'est pas plus compliqué ils
on de quoi quoi alors vous avez
plusieurs thèmes vous avez le thème des
salariés modestes qui disent
travailleurs pauvre modeste c'est dire
qui gagne entre le SMIG et un de SMIG il
a combien le le SMIC le Semic net est à
1400 et brut à 1700 le seuil de pauvreté
alors c'est 60 % du revenu moyen c'est
mais ça dépend puisque c'est fonction du
nombre de personnes dans la famille mais
pour un
célibataire ça doit être à autour de 900
c'est 60 % du revenu moyen voilà si vous
voulez donc la première raison c'est
tous ces salariés modestes qui bossent
et qui disent mais on est les imbéciles
de cette société on n des gens qui
pourraient travailler qui qui veulent
pas travailler ça c'est ravageur je vous
raconter une anecdote j'étais dans une
commune qui s'appelle Parn sursut et
j'étais dans un HLM je faisais ma
campagne et je sonne quelqu'un ouvre me
dit ah bonjour monsieur de Courson je
pens qui me dit vous fatiguez pas aller
chez les voisins je vote pour vous non
non il me dit vous fatiguez pas je vote
rassemblé nationale je dis pourquoi vous
votez rassemblé nationale vous êtes au
chômage non pas du tout alors vous êtes
mal payé non non non je suis tout à fait
bien payé je travaille dans la béurgie
je gagne un bon 2000 € je suis
célibataire alors qu'est-ce qui va pas
il lu dit j'en ai marre de me lever le
matin à 6h 6h30 pour être à l'usine et
de voir je cite cette bande de feignants
hein qui foutent rien et et c'est moi
qui les nourris quoi donc il y a un
moment si cette révolte des gens
modestes il parlait des politiques
comment il parlait des politiques non
c'est c'est de la société si la société
effectivement ne récompense pas euh les
les gens modestes qui travaillent
l'un des grands problèmes de notre
société de ce point de vue-là c'est
l'écart insuffisant entre le smignet
c'està-dire 1400 € et les minimas
sociaux prenez une famille papa maman
deux
enfants qui est au RSA et ben grosso
modo ils vont avoir un niveau de vie pas
très différent de celui qui travaille
qui gagne 14 an mais retirer les frais
professionnels faut prendre la voiture
aller dans les rurales parfois on
travaille il a 10 km 20 km 30 km voyez
quand il voit ce qui leur reste ils
disent la société n'est pas juste c'est
pour ça que je pense que l'une des
grande priorité ça serait
d'écarter les minimas sociaux des
minimas d'activité comment alors par
exemple no collègues de gauche disent il
y a qu'à faucon augmentons de 1400 à
1700 € le smignet c'està dire le SMI
brut qui a 1700 on le porte à 2000 €.
donc là il y a 80 % des fonctionnaires
qui sont au SMIC euh non non non pas du
tout non non non non le fonctionnaire
non non ceux qui sont au SMIG sont une
petite mais si on augmente le SMIC à
1700 € ah bah il est enfin c'est c'est
brutonette là là il raisonne ça
correspond grosso modo disons à 2000 €
brut le problème c'est qu'est-ce qui va
se passer il va se passer que les
emplois peu qualifiés et ben ils seront
automatisé et ils vont disparaître donc
c'est pas ça la bonne solution la bonne
solution ça serait de d'utiliser la
prime d'activité vous savez qui coûte 10
milliards au budget de l'État et la
prime d'activité de la mettre sur la
feuille de paye actuellement les
fonctions de la taille de votre famille
donc ça va pas de de la mettre sur la
feuille de paye à hauteur de 100 150 €
par mois au niveau du SMIC puis après
dégressif jusqu'à 2 3 SMIC et de réduire
les cotisations sociales salarié qui
sont encore sur un SMIC de 300 € puisque
le SMIC brut c'est 1700 SMIC net
j'arrondis c'est c'est 1400 donc si vous
voulez d'essayer de redéployer les
cotisations sociales salarié sur les bas
salaires de l'ORD de 100 150 € et
d'écarter le minimum d'activités les
minimas d'activités des minimas sociaux
il y a combien de zé à 1 milliard bon il
y en a
neu question votre
électeur vous avez toqué à sa porte il
vous a dit juste ça ou il a dit d'autres
chosees non non il m'a dit ça ben je lu
dis mais écoute pas forcément une
solution en plus c'est élection
cantonnal voilà mais mais voilà mais je
cite toujours cet exemple pour montrer
la première raison c'est la révolte des
travailleurs pauvres 55 % des ouvriers
votent rassemblement national voyz et et
sur ce sentiment d'injustice après il y
a d'autres facteurs il y a un facteur
socioc-ulturel qui est que certains ont
sentiment qu'on est plus chez nous ouais
ce sentiment on est plus chez nous voà
c'est la fameuse question de submersion
migratoire c'est ça non c'est pas sous
la forme de submersion c'est disit on n
plus chez nous on voit des gens qui
vivent pas comme nous voyez c'est C idée
alors naturellement en zone rurale entre
nous vous le voyez peu vous ne voyez
cela quand dans des zones urbaines où
sont très concentrés les les immigrés
voilà et et donc ça c'est un deuxième
facteur disons l'immigration mais on
n'est plus chez nous voyez ce sentiment
de perte d'identité vous avez d'autres
facteurs euh vous avez un autre facteur
c'est euh le le le sentiment de perte
d'identité mais qui rejoint un peu ce
deuxè argument si vous voulez après vous
avez chez les agriculteurs et les
viticulteurs
euh qui qui vote de plus en plus pour le
rassemblement national l'idée que on en
a Mar et et et des petits patrons hein
des commerçants des artisans qui disent
on nous accable tous les jours de normes
supplément de contraintte et cetera on
en a marre on en a marre de bosser dans
ces conditions voyez et malgré toutes
les promesses des gouvernements
successif on na jamais
simplifié et donc cette espèce de de
révolte des exploitants agricoles des
viticulteurs voyez chez moi j'ai le cœur
de la Champagne viticole c'estàd si vous
connaissez la Champagne viticole la Côte
des Blancs voyez avise vertu bien quand
vous allez là-bas il faut pas parler des
des des chaômeurs si vous parlez des
chôeurs il vous disent tu veux parler de
ceux qui veulent pas venir travailler
dans les
vignes TR 3 3 et5i % de taux de chômage
donc c'est le c'est le suremploi et et
ils vous disent quand tu penses qu'il
faut qu'on fasse venir de la main
d'œuvre de plus en plus loin parfois
même de l'étranger souvent non euh oui
et notamment en vendange dans les
vendanges en en dans le département de
Laar c'est 100000 contrats donc il y a
100000 personnes qui viennent et bien
savez-vous que maintenant la majorité
sont des étrangers il y a 30 à 40 ans
c'était uniquement des Français qui
venaientent pas de calis enfin un peu
partout vous voyez vous AZ déjà fait les
vendanges
euh non pas je vais au vendange mais
j'ai pas faire au vendange pour picoler
un coup vous allez au vendange pour
picoler un coup et manger un peu non non
je bois je bois très très peu oui pour
serrer des des des pinces non puis voir
comment se passe les
vendanges voilà les problèmes alors ces
problèmes si vous voulez de de main
d'œuvre enfin il y a toujours des
problèmes comme ça quoi de de de de
faire la tournée des coopératives et
cetera et des vendangeoir ou et bien
pour continuer là-dessus dans ces
secteurs là on vous dit c'est pas normal
hein vous nous parlez de chômeurs et Ben
qui viennent travailler dans nos vignes
on trouve plus personne voyez qu-ce
qu'est-ce qu'il vous ont fait remonter
d'autres est-ce qu'ils vous ont fait
monter on a une caste de politique qui
s'en s'en mett plein les fous
ils ne comprennent rien à rien il
n'anticipent pas les problèmes et nous
on est obligé de payer cette incurie oui
alors ça c'est le vieux fond
antiparlementariste français voyez quand
vous interrogez les Français c'est
triste c'est pas nouveau vous les
interrogez comment les Français dans les
sondages prenez les derniers sondages
qui sont sortis he qui sont fait à peu
près une fois par an quand on leur les
interroge sur la façon dont ils
perçoivent les parle entaaires les
journalistes et CEA qu'est-ce qu'il vous
dit sur les parlementaires c'est une
bande de menteurs 75
% c'est une bande de menteurs ils
passent leur temps à nous mentir ils
sont là pour profiter de leur situation
ils ont rien à faire de nos problème
alors quand un électeur me dit ça mais
est-ce que ça s'adresse à moi dit non
non mais toi toi tu es pas comme les
autres oui mais c'est vrai que vous êtes
pas comme les autres peut-être vous avez
un niveau de probité qui est quand même
à la hauteur du pays j'ai toujours
essayé de ne pas dire n'importe quoi
c'està dire une honnêteté intellectuelle
et une honnêteté financière si j'ai vu
m'enrichir j'aurais fait bien vous
gagnez comment combien vous gagnez ben
un parlementaire net d'impôt moi je
gagne 4700 net d'impôt et encore parce
que je suis rapporteur général avant
avantag B j'ai à
Paris un
chauffeur qui me rememmène chez moi la
nuit voilà et le reste du temps de ma
circonscription c'est moi qui conduis ou
des bén vol quand je suis trop fatigué
qui me conduisent votre patrimoine
s'élève à combien et ben je déclare àifi
un peu plus de 2 millions voilà comment
vous avez assemblé 2 millions ah ben
c'est très simple j'ai eu le malheur de
perdre mon père jeune j'avais 33 ans P à
son âme
voilà qui était riche voilà il faisait
quoi comment il faisait quoi mon père
était avait trois vies il était
exploitant agricole il était pisiculteur
pour être précis exploitant agricole il
était élu local il était maire et
conseiller général et il s'occupait de
de de tas de choses voilà sur la
construction euh voilà dans la Marne et
la Haute Marne d'ailleurs et en plus il
était inspecteur général des finances il
était haut fonctionnaire il était rentré
inspection des finances l'un des
derniers concours à à la sortie de la
guerre voilà il était rentré fin 44 le
concours de la Libération voilà il était
résistant il vous a laissé un peu de
sous
euh non j'ai pas fait de sous il vous a
laissé un peu de sous oui oui il m'a
laissé à l'époque 600000 € d'ancien
francs non non 600000 € de maintenant
oui vous avez été taxé à combien dessus
et ben on a payé le taux vous savez il y
a des abattements des trucs des machins
comme on est si frères et sœurs si vous
voulez c'est l'ensemble qui a payé on a
dû payer je sais pas 10 15 % puisqueon
divise par 6 puis après le Baram
s'applique par part avec des
abattements selon la nature des biens
enfin et cetera voilà et vous avez placé
cet argent non c'était pas de l'argent
moi je demandais à mes frères et sœurs
mon père était amoureux des bois
j'aurais demandé de me donner que des
bois et donc on m'a donné des bois voilà
j'aime beaucoup les bois voilà vous avez
une forêt
euh j'ai quelques blocs mais j'ai
beaucoup de parcelles aussi disséminées
voilà et j'aime les bois bon voilà
pourquoi vous aimez les bois parce que
je voulais être
libre ça vous étonne he pas du tout ici
vous êtes sur une cha voulais être libre
et et moi aussi j'aime les bois et mon
père m'emmenait dans ses bois me
montrait ses bois et cetera voilà et et
et donc
euh j'ai un certain patrimoine
maintenant parce que je vis simplement
voouz j'ai pas j'ai pas de vill à
saintrope tout tout ça je sors pas en
boîte c'est pas mon truc vous voyez
prenez pas de drogue non je suis pas
drogué euh je bois des des des des
coupettes hein comme on dit chez nous de
champagne c'est tout voyez et qu la
différence entre une coupe et une flute
ah bien une coupe c'est vous savez que
on prétend que c'était le sein de
Marie-Antoinette il paraît que c'est
totalement inexact d'illeurs
d'aprèsarien donc c'est la coupe et la
flû elle est droite et les spécialistes
de champagne recommand toujours la flute
pourquoi parce que la coupe perd son son
gaz assez vite vu l'ampleur alors que
dans une flûte c'est beaucoup plus
étroit qu'est-ce que c'est le mer captan
le mer captan je sais pas d'accord
revenons au bois vos bois vous avez quel
type d'essence dessus est-ce que les
chinois ont essayé de vous acheter vos
chaînes bah oui j'ai surtout des chaînes
un peu de Pelier enfin la dominante
c'est quand même des chaînes un peu de
peliers comprenez ma question pourquoi
je vous pose la question non mais je je
vais ven dire et un jour il y avait un
bois auquel tenait beaucoup mon père
quand on visitait ce bois là il me
disait tu vois c'est des superbes
chaînes voilà qu'il faudra un jour
couper voilà et donc j'ai un plan simple
de gestion et donc était venu le le
moment de les couper alors je je mets ça
avec quelqu'un qui met d'une coopérative
forestière locale et un marchand de bois
on prend le le meilleur offrant et je
vends un bon prix d'ailleurs combien
l'aster euh je crois qu'à l'époque
c'était je crois 150000 € mais c'était
un beau bois c'était c'était un bois qui
devait faire 18 hectares mais on en a
coupé qu'une partie pour replanter par
bande et on en a laisser des bandes
voilà et puis quelques mois plus tard je
crois c'est un marchand de bois alors je
dis qu'est-ce que vous avez fait du Lot
que vous m'avez acheté ah bah c'est
simple les 20 % les plus beaux direction
Bordeaux pour faire des tonneau des
tneau pour le bordeaux et les 80 %
autres en containire direction la
Chine donc là on va pouvoir aborder le
sujet de guerre économique le fait que
des États sont prédateurs sur nos
ressources sur le peu de ressources
qu'on peut avoir vous avez quel avis sur
cette guerre économique qui qui livre la
France à des Vau tours quel quel quels
avis quel avis vous avez sur ceux qui
vendent la France à la découpe alors je
ne dirais pas cela je dirais que il y a
un problème de compétitivité la
compétitivité d'un pays ça se mesure
c'est essentiellement son industrie il y
a aussi des services c'est vrai mais le
gros morceau c'est l'industrie et ça se
mesure par la balance commerciale
c'estàdire est-ce qu'on exporte plus
qu'on importe ou l'inverse bon vous
savez que la France moin 156 milliards
oui c'est ça alors c'est vrai que dans
cette partie là il y a une partie
énergétique c'est vrai mais l'Allemagne
est équilibrée même elle est
suréquilibrée
donc c'est une des mesures de de de de
la faible compétitivité française mais
en fait la compétitivité française elle
est très variable selon les secteurs
prenez la compétitivité dans le domaine
de l'aviation bah le groupe Airbus
exporte beaucoup on est bon prenez les
produits de luxe on est très bon voilà
on était aussi très bon dans l'agro
industrie alors ça se dégrade beaucoup
on est quasiment je crois euh à
l'équilibre même en léger déficit voyez
donc euh les 20 on est très excédentaire
mais ça se dégrade vous voyez donc on a
un problème de compétitivité et ceux qui
croient que on va protéger notre
industrie en élevant des barrières
douanières non plus au niveau français
mais au niveau européen puisque les
tarifs douiniers sont une compétence
européenne ils se trompent complètement
pourquoi ils se trompent complètement
parce qu'il voit pas c'est ce qui va se
passer d'ailleurs aux États-Unis si
Monsieur Trump maintient durablement ses
25 % de droit de douane et 40 % de la
consommation des des américains est
importé
donc pardon si vous mettez une taxe sur
les importation de 25 % les prix vont
flomber il y a pas besoin d'avoir fait
Polytechnique pour comprendre ça or il a
combattu Joe Biden Joe Biden c'est à
cause de lui qu'il a eu l'inflation et
là les gens ils vont voir l'inflation
repartir voyez et donc c'est pas la la
la bonne mesure des mesures
protectionnistes tarifaires ou non
tarifaires he parce qu'il y a aussi tout
Le non tarifaire peut-être une politique
intelligente pour protéger pendant
quelques années une industrie lui
permettant de se remettre à niveau de se
moderniser de devenir compétitive et à
ce moment-là on abaisse les les les
droits de douane ça c'est une politique
intelligente ouais mais mais mais croire
que des droits de douane durable vont
protéger notre industrie et nos emplois
alors là c'est c'est ça c'est une erreur
fondamentale tous ceux qui ont joué à ce
jeu-là l'ont payé très cher le sang de
l'industrie son carburant c'est quoi
c'est l'énergie ah bah il a je dirais
que il y a deux choses il y a
effectivement il y a l'énergie et les
données
ouais bon c'est et de plus en plus les
les les les données si vous voulez on
voit bien que le développement de l'IA
est un élément de compétitivité des
industrie et ceux qui ne se mettront pas
à lia et ben ils auront une perte de
compétitivité ils le paieront par une
contraction de vente voilà ça ça c'est
c'est c'est c'est une quasi certitude
vous savez quand les Canu Lyonnais ont
cru qu'ils allaient protéger l'industrie
textile lyonnaise en
cassant les
nouveaux équipement de tissage ben ils
ont réussi à rien du tout si ils ont
cassé d'accord mais qu'est-ce qu'on fait
pour l'énergie bah pour l'énergie c'est
une affaire compliquée parce que la
France a fait dans les années 70 un
énorme programme
électronucléaire on remercie
bernardombert et oui et valétin et
quelques autres qui
es Pompidou Pompidou et Mesmer qui voilà
qui ont poussé pierre comment pierre
pierre mes oui oui pierre et on s'est
retrouvé si vous voulez avec nos 49
réacteurs ou 59 réacteurs
ou non non parce qu'on fermé de à
l'époque voilà encore une idée brillante
oui
oui s'il y avait bien de réacteurs qu'
fallait pas fermer
c'était l' fermé ben on l'a fermé parce
que François Hollande l'avait promis il
l'a même pas fait c'est son successeur
qui l'a fait je vous avourz que c'est
quand même grandiose moi j'y suis allé
hein puisque j'avais un ami qui
connaissait très bien le directeur de
Fessenheim et je dis je vais aller me
rendre compte sur place alors ais j'ai
passé très grande après-midi il m'a tout
fait visicité il venait d'investir 300
millions pour remettre tout à niveau
parce que vous c'est c'est le long du
canal du RIN voilà et donc en cas de
rupture euh du des di du canal ça
pouvait inonder donc c'était pas prévu à
l'époque où ça a étit fait enfin bon et
en plus fenheim était une coopérative
une coopérative entre EDF
RWE le le le distributeur allemand
d'électricité du du
sud sud sud-ouest de l'Allemagne et deux
distributeurs d'électricité Suisse et
qui avait cofinancé avec EDF ce qui fait
Queen fait on faisait les comptes en
ramortissement et donc c'est vrai que
c'était extrêmement intéressant et on a
fermé ça
voilà c'est vraiment une folie donc on a
la chance en matière électrique d'avoir
une une assez large indépendance parce
qu'on a développé en plus que ce soit
l'éolien le photovoltaïque quel que soit
les critiques notamment l'éolien
maritime on peut discuter de l'intérêt
de l'éolien maritime ENF passçonin on a
et puis d'hydraulique mais on a équipé
toutes les vallées si vous voulez et
sont sont quasiment terminé et donc on a
maintenant donc une
indépendance énergétique électrique très
élevé l' des plus élevé et si on
considère que une fois que la centrale
est construite on produit de
l'électricité verte je dis une fois
qu'elle est construite parce que pour la
construire on consomme du C2 hein bon
mais mais on les a ces centrales donc
voilà on
a une décarbonation
de la partie électrique de l'énergie
française le plus
élevé le plus élevé de toute l'Europe
quand vous dites une
folie c'est une folie c'est une
incompétence c'est un manque de prisme
de lecture c'est un manque
d'anticipation c'était pourz Françis
pour gâter sa frange écologiste c'était
quoi François Hollande a été interviewé
par un de vos collègues sur on n pas de
collègu interview François Hollande non
non mais vos collègues journalistes on
n'est pas journaliste ah bon Bonon enfin
disons des journalistes l'ont interviewé
et ont poser la question monsieur le
Président pourquoi dans votre campagne
électorale à l'issu de laquelle vous
avez été élu président vous êtes engagé
à réduire de on était à peu près 75 % en
électriquein alimenté par nos centrales
nucléairirees vous avez dit on doit
descendre à 50 % vous vous souvenez de
ce qu'il a qu'il a sa réponse c'est
extraordinaire il a répondu
bah j'avais besoin des voies vertes et
cetera voilà il répond voilà c'était un
truc purement politique il y avait aucun
fondement on avait jamais étudié cela
d'ailleurs il ne l'a pas respecté il na
pas respecté ce 50 % voyez on est encore
à 65 67 % grâce au développement de
l'éolien et et et du photovoltaïque
l'éolien actuellement doit être à 8 9 %
hein de la production électrique et on
doit être à 4 5 5 % je crois maintenant
en en photovoltaïque et puis 12 13 % en
hydraulique vous trouvez que vos
collègues il matrise correctement les
dossiers ou c'est simplement des des
commerciaux de partis politiques avec le
respect que je peux avoir pour les
commerciaux ça ça dépend si vous voulez
des collègues ça dépend des domaines
vous savez personne n'est omniscient
mais est-ce qu'il y a une base sur les
sujets
régaliens sur les sujets à 30 atts je
vous vois lever les mains lever les
sourcils alors ça ça ça c'est une
d'autre question là on quitte l'énergie
parce que jeis pas répondu sur gaz vous
pas répondu sur le gaz et sur le pétrole
où leur proportion
baissera moins vite par la déplession ou
par les engagements non par
l'électrification c'est-à-dire des
voitures mais on est parti compris au
niveau européen dans des objectifs
complètement délirants les voitures
comparées à l'industrie consomment
beaucoup plus de pétrole ou pas du tout
les voitures par rapport à l'industrie
bah oui le transport c'est un véhicule
de particulier et puis poids lourd
grosso modo c'est on dit toujours c'est
3/ers vous avez un/ers logement un/ers
industrie et un/ers transport modo c'est
pas tout à fait c'est proportion mais
c'est l'ORD de grandeur donc on voit
bien que certains pensaient qu'on aller
électrifier le parc automobile très vite
voyez quand vous pensez que Parlement
européen a é voté une folie qui est 2035
plus de moteur thermique mais enfin il y
a des consommateurs les voitures
électriques sont plus cherses que des
voitures de même catégorie thermique
donc on peut pas indéfiniment faire des
primes comme l'ont fait beaucoup de pays
européens dont la franceyz on parlait
d'économie est-ce que c'est raisonnable
on était à 6000 € par véhicule he là on
est descendu à 5000 mais est-ce que
c'est raisonnable tout ça est-ce qu'il
faut pas laisser le marché
se développer avec des pars de marché
qui monteront gentiment qui ne
déstabiliseront pas complètement
l'industrie
automobile européenne moi c'est ma
position
mais les politiques en Europe pas
simplement en France ce sont embarqué
dans un truc et on est en train de
rétropédaler par manque de sagesse et et
et d'examen je trouve au fond revenons
sur vos collègues vous savez quelle est
la proportion de voitur électrique dans
en Europe en 202
24 on est à 12 13 % donc les hybrides
c'est 17 18 si vous voulez donc la somme
des deux on est à 30 à peu près mais les
les hybrides qui ont beaucoup plus de
succès que les voitures électriques
fonctionnent plus au thermique
qu'àélectrique vous avez une voiture oui
qu'est-ce que c'est comme modèle alors
j'ai un modèle Peugeot voilà une 508
Peugeot voilà euh turbo en plus et
quelle finition comment quelle finition
GT
gr tourisme non alors c j'ta vous savez
moi c'est c'est une utilité pour moi les
voitures je dire je ne la lave jamais
comme ça est assez crassuse on l'a
jamais volé grâce à
çaz mes s ta voiture h je
écoute problème mais cétait la dernière
diesel dans la concession puisquils
avaient rêé la production
et et donc j'ai j'ai cette voiture là
donc je suis très satisfait j'avais déjà
des8 critère comment quelle vignette
vous avez une vignette critère dessus
oui bien sûr quel numéro alors max c'est
quoi max ah critère 1 oui oui alors on
va attendre de repasser sur la question
de vos collègues qu'est-ce que vous
pensez des zones à faible
émission alors je suis très
plus que prudent sur cette idée pourquoi
parce que l'idée de faire une ZFE en
centrreeville ça quelle conséquence vous
reportez la pollution sur la périphérie
de la ville or dans la plupart des
villes c'est vrai pas toutes qui vit en
centrreeville plutôt des gens aisés tout
simplement parce que le prix des
logements est plus élevé et qui vit dans
les zones périphériques plutôt les
couchement modeste les guux donc donc je
dirais pas pas les gu je mais des gens
modestes donc ça consiste à repousser
les Guu en dehors des villes il y a eu
une étude très intéressante faite à
Paris quand on a piétonnisé les voies
surberg qu'est-ce qui s'est passé et
bien les des embouteillages sur les qua
c'est épouvantable et surtout comme les
gens si vous voulez veulent plus passer
par là ils passent par le périphérique
donc on a augmenté la pollution sur la
périphérique hein autour du périphérique
et cetera et sur sur les quai voyez et
donc est-ce que socialement une telle
politique est astucieuse moi j'en
discutais avec mon ami le maire de rein
arnud robinet puisque comme il est
au-dessus du seuil il devait
obligatoirement faire une ZFE alors je
dis comment tu vas faire je faire le
truc à minima parce qu'il me dit je vois
bien les les les critique dont je vais
faire l'objet alors que c'est pas moi
qui eu cette géniale
idée qu est-ce qui a eu cette géniale
idée et ben des des antibagnoles c'est
c'est une idée des veres qui trouvent
que c'est une très bonne idée moi je dis
non c'est pas une bonne idée c'est une
idée antisocial en plus ce qu'il faut
c'est réduire les émissions quce qui va
se passer quand les guux vont perdre
leur sang
froid ah bah à se prendre des lois dans
la tête fait par des gens fait par des
gens conneecté de la réalité et ben les
gens ils cassent voilà il manifestent
voir ils cassent cass quand quand vous
poussez les gens à bout voz je prends
des livreurs alors livreurs comment
comment vous faites vous avez une
voiture diesel hein et et vous livrez
dans ces
ZFE est-ce qu'on va vous dire ah benah
non alors certains disent bah vous allez
livrer dans des dans des sites
intermédiaires et puis avec une voiture
électrique ils vont reprendre de de de
de ces de ces pôles pour livrer au sein
de la ZFE mais je lu dis à à quel coûte
à quel coûte pour le consommateur vous
êtes déjà allé à zermat jamais à zermat
il y a pas de voiture oui il y a même il
y a même des chevaux parce que j'ai vu
des films là-dessus il y a il y a des
chevaux voilà mais ça fait partie du
folklore vous connaissez le le prix du
forfait à zermat non parce que je ne
vais pas faire du ski alors mais il doit
être très élevé vous connaissez le prix
de la bière à zermat 1500 non le le le
forfait non ENF dépend la semaine non
mais on connait pas la semaine nous
c'est trop cher à la journée la journée
la journée plus de 100 € Ah oui ah oui
oui bon par contre les toilettes sont
propres ah oui tout est propre mais
c'est une sélection par le pognon par
l'argent oui absolument mais si c'est la
politique Mo de la commune de
zermat c'est leur problème mais qu'on
vienne pas me dire que socialement c'est
formidable il y a pas beaucoup de
mixité pas du tout qu'est-ce qui se
passe quand il y a pas de mixité
des colèr il y a ah bah ça peut mal
tourner si vous voulez avec des gens
tellement exaspérés qui manifestent et
quand on les entend pas bah ils peuvent
aller jusqu'à casser voyez c'est le
phénomène des gilets jaunes ouis les
gilets jaunes moi j'ai eu ce phénomène
chez moi hein je suis allé sur les sur
les barrages j'en connaissais beaucoup
il y avait vraiment de tout et je disais
mais pourquoi vous manifestez disait
tous on en a marre voilà on décide pour
nous les gars qui font ça on a
l'impression qu'ils ont jamais vécu qui
vivent dans des bulles ouais mais voilà
et ben on en a
marre
et le
Président je veux vous dire Mo ce que me
disaient les gens c'était pas très
sympathique he c'était du genre quoi on
repart sur nos vieux démons français
régicide
B vous savez des Français sont des
royalistes régicides ils aiment bien
choisir leur roi mais ils aiment bien
aussi lui couper la tête mais comme on
est en démocratie on coupe plus les
têtes vous pensez qu'on est encore en
démocratie bah la démocratie c'est le
pouvoir du peuple pour le peuple par le
peuple voyez il y a encore des élections
voilà sont écouté comment qui sont
écoutés bah les les les
parlementaires oui S se regroupent en
différents courants politiques s'ils
sont un peu entre com prenant oui ils
peuvent se faire écouter d'autant plus
quand il y a pas de majorité si vous
voulez ça ça augmente le le le le
pouvoir de du Parlement puisque depuis
58 il y avait toujours eu pratiquement
tout le temps une majorité parce qu'on
dit où il y a le précédent de recard FO
du monter 4 C sièges ça se négocie
toujours il y a toujours des non
inscrits des trucs voyez c'est la
première fois qu'on a la deuxième fois
pour être précis parce que la fois
précédente il leur manquait 40 sièges
voyz là ils sont revenus à 160 alors
même si vous rajoutez les républicains
qui sont je crois 47 ils sont allez on
va faire simple ils sont 210 210 la
majorité c'est
289 donc on voit bien que et donc si les
gens sont présents premièrement
actif et s'occupe des affaires oui vous
pouvez faire passer des choses le taux
d'absentéisme chez vous c'est combien
l'absentisme des parlementaires des
parlementaires moi-même ou les
parlementaires vous et les
parlementaires ah ben moi je je je je
suis pratiquement toujours présent je
veux dire je suis toujours là le mardi
le mercredi et si je suis absent dans
tel dans en séance sur tel texte parce
que je suis en commission par exemple
cet après-midi il y avait un texte qui
m'intéressait beaucoup qui est de notre
groupe sur l'Ukraine hein et il y avait
simultanément l'audition des
représentants des départements par la
commission d'enquête sur les causes des
écarts d'où ça vient donc ça a duré 2h3
he l'audition et donc après je suis allé
tout de suite en séance et puis mon
collaborateur est venu me récupérer en
disant attention on doit être
à à 18h30 et donc je suis sorti arrivé à
18h29 voilà revenons à ma question des
inégalités des guux et des
députés
déconnectés de la réalité
oui alors c'est un débat si vous
voulez
pourquoi certains parlementaire donne le
sentiment d'être complètement déconnecté
il y a une première raison c'est la loi
anticumule autrefois beaucoup de députés
étaient adjoints maire vice-président de
conseil généraux président de conseil
généraux donc ils avaient un vrai
encrage territorial donc quand il
voyaent des textes mais ça va pas du
tout c'est chez moi c'est inapplicable
votre truc ça va pas voyez alors
qu'aujourd'hui euh vous avez beaucoup de
de députés ce qu'on appelle horsol ils
ne sont que députés eu ils n'ont jamais
eu de fonction locale voyez donc alors
ceux-là de temps en temps il ils ont du
mal hein parce qu'ils voient pas ils
voient pas les problèmes
Z alors ça c'est quand même nouveau euh
de par l'ampleur du phénomène vous avez
le le deuxième élément c'est que
ça tourne beaucoup si je vous posez la
question connaissez-vous l'espérance de
vie d'un député pas l'espérance de vie
mais ça dépend en temps de crise ou pas
en temps de crise non c'est si vous
prenez sur 15 20 ans et ben c'est 7 ans
c'està dire un mandat et demi donc
beaucoup de députés sont élus dans une
vague et batttu dans la
contevague et ça tourne et ça tourne et
ça tourne alors c'est vrai moi je suis
considéré comme une anomalie alors de
temps en temps les collègues viennent me
voir un ovenu oui alors des cèg de tout
mort d'ailleurs viennent me voir en
disant Charles toi qui est là depuis 32
ans est-ce que tu pourrais nous dire
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé sur telle
chose j'ai beaucoup fait rire lors du
débat sur la loi de finance pour 2025
puisque notre collègue lefur qui lui a
arrêté à son 6e mandat de mémoire oui 6
mandats c'est son fils qui lui a succédé
et son fils a repris des amendement j'ai
dit vous êtes le digne fils de votre
père mon cher cègue puisque vous nous
ressortez toujours la même chose c'était
sur la demi-part voilà pour les veuves
et cetera je lu dis écoutez cette
affaire a été tranchée par le Conseil
constitutionnel voyez alors mais c'est
vrai que je ne seraai pas là depuis 32
ans il faut dans toute société un
équilibre voyez il faut pas que des
petits
jeunes qui sont là qui vont être battus
5 ans plus tard qui vont disparaître ou
que des vieux des vieux ch comme on
disait autre fois qui sont là qui
s'accrochent voilà quel ge vous avez moi
j'ai 72 ans vous comptez prendre une
retraite un jour
oui oui vous savez général de Gaul
disait il faut savoir quitter les
affaires avant qu'elle ne vous quitte
ouais qu'elle vous rattrape ou qu'elle
vous rattrape pour certains pour
certains oui c'est vrai mais non non
j'arriverai mais le problème
actuellement c'est que autrefois c'était
pour 5 ans actuellement si je vous
demandais quelle est l'espérance de vie
des députés qui ont été élus il y a un
peu moins d'un an ça dépend en temps de
crise ou pas en temps de crise bah là en
temps de crise
voyez la fois précédente ils ont fait 2
ans hein les collègues là je sais pas si
on dépassera l'année donc pour répondre
à votre question il y a des
circonstances dans lesquelles qui
m'inciteraiit à à me représenter parf là
c'était au bout de 2 ans je me suis
représenté faut combien d'années de
députation pour avoir une retraite
pleine alors je crois qu'il faut faire 5
mandat après vous cotisez pour le roi de
Prusse bon j'attends pas ça revenons au
niveau intellectuel au background de vos
collègues vous qui avez de
l'ancienneté est-ce que vous trouvez qui
ils maîtrisent leurs dossierers est-ce
qu'ils se sont appropriés leurs
dossierers ces dossiers qui sont
nécessaires à la France pour survivre
dans un climat de guerre économique
agressive ces dossiers de géopolitique
de finances de guerre économique de
soutenabilité énergétique je vais pas
vous dire
l'évacuation des déchets mais est-ce
qu'ils connaissent les principes de
soutenabilité de nos sociétés
thermo-industrielles quand on écoute vos
collègues sur les questions géopolitique
d'énergie de guerre économique on a
l'impression
d'entendre des
commerciaux vous blablat une fiche qu'on
leur a pondu et on les sent pas
réellement animé alors ça suffit pour
régaler le
chalent régaler les plateaux télé
s'invectiv mais face à ceux qui
maîtrisent pleinement les dossiers on a
l'impression de voir des pentin
àbleur alors j'ai des collègues qui me
dit Charles puisque tu es là depuis 32
ans est-ce que le niveau baisse c'est la
question est-ce que le niveau baisse je
dis écoute première réflexion faisons
attention ce que j'appelle le syndrome
du vieux con savez ce que c'est syndrome
du vieux con c'était toujours mieux
avant et tout fcan et tous dégrade donc
ceci étant
rappelé moi quand je suis arrivé en
93 il y avait des pointures à gauche à
droite au centre il y avait des
pointures des nom des noms bah à droite
il y avait badure il y avait Chirac il y
avait
déjà d'autres il y avait segin
son âme à son âme il y avait et Chirac
aussi il y avait des et Baladur est
encore de ce monde donc il y avait des
pointures à la droite et au centre il y
avait bar il y avait bar moi j'étais
bariste il y avait bar Raymon Raymond la
science comme on le surnommait et quand
il prenait la parole les gens se
taisaient ouais alors il était il avait
ce ton un peu professoral et à gauche il
y avait aussi des pointurees hein bah il
y avait à l'époque des gens comment
non non marché n'était plus là marché
n'était plus là non non chez les
communistes il y avait plus de de de de
l'équivalent de marché pendant pendant
15 20 ans non mais mais il y avait au
Parti
socialiste des gens comme il y avait des
JS il y avait des rards il y avait enfin
il y avait il y avait Chevénement il y
avait il y avait des pointures si je
vous demandais aujourd'hui de reprendre
courant politique par courant politique
et de me dire où sont les hommes ou les
femmes
é dans chacune de ces il y en a plus
beaucoup hein ça c'est vrai
et je pense que le le l'excès moi j'ai
voté pour le le le N cumule voilà mais
j'avais proposé qu'on mette un seuil un
seuil peut-être de 1000 habitants on
peut discuter 1000 2000 voyez que les
gens qui sont dans des petites communes
des petites interc garde un ancrage
territorial est-ce qu'il y a beaucoup
d'alcooliques de drogués
d'alcoolique parmi les et de drogués bah
les drogués on a découvert qu'un de nos
collègues s'approvisionnait dans le
métro voilà
oui il y en a certainement il y en a
certainement mais est-ce que c'est une
proportion différente-il que la Buvette
chez vous c'est un peu le repère des
popoches il y a beaucoup alors de moins
en moins parce que je discutais avec moi
je vais très rarement mais quand j'y
vais je je connais les les serveurs
alors on discute et ils me disent que
c'est plus ce que
c'était c'est-à-dire que les les jeunes
générations consomment de moins en moins
d'alcool est-ce que vous êtes pour moi
j'ai connu j'ai connu des collègues qui
étaient des vrais alcolos en quelle
année et ben dans les années que des
années 90 voyez quand j'étais jeune
parlementaire je me souviens un jour
d'un d'un d'entre eux c'est une histoire
célèbre on discutait sur le Pax bon et
alors on était en séance et il s'était
assoupi parce que avait il avait un Bubu
bon tout se passe bien il dormait bon ça
va il ronflait pas comme parfois on
l'entend et puis à un moment il se
lève et alors là il déraille
complètement il dit ouais cette bande de
péd je leur pisse sur l'arrêt du cul non
mais attendez alors on s'est levé à deux
collègues on a mis voilà on dit je crois
qu'il est temps d'aller de coucher bon
il a fini quand même par s'excuser vous
voyez ben mais il était voilà l'Anci
l'ancien maire de La
Rochelle il était aussi en début
d'après-midi il était un peu mur comme
on dit he est-ce que vous êtes pour des
contrôles aléatoires pour les
stupéfiants et le taux d'alcoolémie ah
oui j'ai vu que une journaliste
d'ailleursise lu oui oui j'ai dit à
celui qui m'a dit ça mais si elle veut
elle peut venir elle peut elle me prend
un cheveux hein puisque je crois que où
on fait dans dans la bouche on peut
faire les deux c'est plus intéressant je
crois les cheveux parce qu'on m'a
expliqué que il y a une concentration
non il y a l'historicité voilà voilà
pour avoir cela mais il y a certainement
des gens qui se drogu puis il y a drogue
et drogue voyez est-ce que c'est quoi
drogue et drogue bah il y a drogue et
drogue si vous voulez entre de la drogue
dure
type cocaïne et ceux qui prennent des
amphétamines vont tenirz voilà c'est
c'est c'est il y a une graduation vous
êtes pour la légalisation du
cannabis si vous voulez oui ou non euh
non plutôt non parce que je vois si vous
voulez les dégâts voyez quand je discute
avec les enseignants je vois les dégâts
que ça fait sur les jeunes et sur leurs
neurones et et maintenant les les les
profs me disent dans des classes de 25
30 ils en ont systématiquement au moins
un car on est à 2 à 3 % la jeune
génération qui consomme tous les jours
et ça c'est destructeur moi j'ai des
amis qui sont venus voir voir un ami il
avait récupéré un de ses neveux qui
allait pas bien enfin je vous passe les
détails et puis il me dit tu sais j'ai
du mal avec lui et cetera il me dit bah
tu sais il n'accepte plus rien et cetera
mais Jie tu es sûr que il fume
pas ah je m'étais pas posé la question
ben j'ai dit vérifie il a vérifié bah
oui il fumait la moquette com on dit
chez les jeunes il fumait la moquette et
alors je lui ai dit écoute hein si tu
veux sauver ce gamin hein change
d'établissement tout de suite metle en
pension loin pour le couper de de ses
réseaux d'alimentation et il s'est pas
il s'est pas posé la question pourquoi
le gamin se drogué il a pas eu une
conduite introspective bah non enfin
c'était une situation compliquée il
avait récupéré ce gamin revenons
revenons à nos moutons nos députés ils y
connaissent quelque chose en guerre
économique en guerre tout court
ou il se font fiouler par des cabinets
de conseil pour écrire les lois est-ce
qu'il bossent
alors c'est comme dans toute
collectivité humaine vous avez de tout
vous avez des gens qui travaillent
beaucoup vous avez AZ deux qui en font
pas lourd vous avez pas l'impression que
la proportion de mégalo ou de cas un peu
spéciaux arrivé à une certaine fonction
il y a quand même petite concentration
de mais si c'est c'est un peu comme les
artistes euh c'est des artistes ben non
mais ce syndrome considéré comme des
artistes moi non mais comme des peintres
peut-être artistes peintre je dirais pas
ça mais si vous voulez le fait d'être
exposé si vous voulez d'être reconnu il
y a des gens ça leur tourne la tête
hein ça leur tourne la tête moi j'ai
horreur de ça vous voyez quand je fais
mon voyage annuel je suis à l'autre bout
du monde
et mais vous êtes monsieur de Courson
bon j'ai j'ai parfois envie de dire non
c'est pas moi
ouis euh pour avoir la paix quoi voilà
non je le fais pas je dis oui c'est bien
moi alors on discute voilà mais mais
c'est vrai que euh vous avez des gens
qui qui vivent voyez ils vivent du
regard des autres revenons sur les
dossiers ils maîtrisent leur dossierers
bah là encore ça ça dépend lesquels on
va prendre la guerre en Ukraine bah la
guerre en Ukraine là elle est en plein
débat encore toute cette nuit on va
continuer sur la résolution de notre
groupe he sur le soutien à l'Ukraine
et et bah il y a de tout il y a de tout
je sais pas si on parle de la CED 1954
s' y a beaucoup d'en sortant j'ai un
collègue de gauche qui me dira tu sais
on est presque du temps de la CED dans
lequel les Gaulistes et la et les la
droite nationaliste s'est allié avec le
Parti communiste pour échouer de peu
d'ailleurs la la la CED bon c'est une
question d'histoire mais on voyait
certaines voilà ENF c'est l'histoire se
répète pas de ce point de vuelà mais
vous voyez c'est on voit que certains
ont une connaissance de l'histoire ou ou
des des dossiers je discutais avec le
président Hollande en disant ça sert à
rien de dire on dépense 50 milliards en
fait pour notre défense il faut le
porter à à 100 milliards et je dis on
est incapable il faut encore une
industrie d'armement hein et donc il
faut du temps ça se fait pas déjà on met
3 milliards supplémentaires d'ailleurs
quand vous regardez les comptes vous
voyez qu' une partie de cet argent qui
est reporté les crédits sont reportés
parce que euh ça suit pas si vous voulez
donc faut du temps il faut trouver les
personnels il faut élargir les usines
installer de nouveau matériel ça se fait
pas par un claquement de doigt quoi
connaissez le proverbe à ne jamais rien
anticiper on finit toujours par se faire
surprendre ah oui c'est vrai mais c'est
qu quand il y a la guerre aux portes de
la France oui mais pourquoi en ce qu' on
est là parce que au fond on a vécu
pendant 75 ans de 45 à il y a mais me
faites pas le coup des dividendes de la
paix non non non non non non on a vécu
euh dans l'idée que et surtout après
l'effondrement en
1989 de tous les pays communistes de
l'Est européen on a dit l'Europe on est
en paix éternelle donc certains disaient
les divvidend de la paix et cetera moi
j'ai j'aime bien l'histoire hein je dis
souvent chers amis moi je sais que je ne
sais pas donc quand on se sait qu'on ne
sait pas et bien la prudence c'est quand
même avoir un outil militaire digne de
ce nom capable de défendre le pays car
on ne sait jamais ce qui peut arriver
vous voyez ce qui est en train d'arriver
on est 4 ans en arrière je vous dirais
voilà ce qui va arriver vous direz non
mais c'est pas possible si si si nous on
a anticipé la guerre ben voilà et ben
pourtant c'est ce qui c'est ce qui est
arrivé voyez et et les gens en plus ne
veulent pas écouter c'est pas un peu
facile ça cette position quoi donc le
dire voilà on s'est endormi sur nous
l'orier mais c'est un constat c'est un
constat c'est un constat que il y a pas
des services de l'État avec des gens
formés pour être
paranoïque je vais pas dire paranoïque
alerte
oui
mais tous ces gens vous répondent que il
y a pas de dangerz un jour la Commission
des finance je vous raconter c'est quand
même assez
intéressant dit mais est-ce que nos
moyens militaires sont adaptés aux
missions que le pouvoir politique à
donner à notre armée alors on appelle le
chef d'état-major qui était monsieur de
viler pierre de viler
qui a été viré avant ouais avant de dire
ou peut-être qu' est parti oui oui euh
celui qui disait qu'il fallait qu'on
renforce nos budgets c'est ça type très
très bien non non non on l'a auditionné
il a dit d'accord mais à H clos donc on
déclare huit clos on était entre nous on
les pose la question de base est-ce que
notre outil de de défense actuellement
est adapté aux missions de l'armée il
nous a répondu mais d'une façon
impeccable il nous a dit au regard des
missions qui nous ont été euh par le
affecté par le pouvoir politique la
réponse est non donc il nous a dit de
deux choses l'une soit vous réduisez nos
missions pour que ça soit cohérent avec
l'enveloppe voilà soit si vous voulez
maintenir les missions bah encore
faut-il augmenter les moyens pour qu'on
soit capable de faire face voyez moi
certains disaient parce que j'avais
garder quelques intérêts puisque j'étais
capitaine voilà j'étais hsè voilà donc
les les questions de défense
m'intéressaient toujours donc quand je
rencontrais des militaires on discutait
du de l'opérationnalité de nos matériels
enfin quand vous voyez que nos
hélicoptères de combat à l'époque
hein il y en avait je
crois 30 40
% incapable voir un début de
canabalisation ce qu'on appelle c'est-à-
direire qu'on va prendre des pièces pour
voyez donc les hélicoptère de combat euh
les les nos charats moi j'étais dans les
temp hein euh qui tombait en panne enfin
quand on voyaeit qu'on partait en
manœuvre au bout de 30 km on avait déjà
perdu 15 à 20 % de nos tanks bon
attendez quand vous voyez ça vous posez
des questions non il y avait le problème
des stocks de munition hein quelle année
comment quelle année ça le le le ces
questions là oh bah c'est il y a il y a
il y a 15 ans 15 ans oui Devillier c'est
moins puisque c'était sous Macron donc
Devillier ça devait être il y a 4 ans 5
ans voyez les stocks de munition tout le
monde savait que ce qu'on appelait des
guerres de haute intensité c'est-à-dire
ce qui se passe en Ukraine nous
tienderion alors les uns disent une
semaine les autres 10ent 15 jours bon
peu importe mais que nos stocks euh de
munition était capable de faire face à
entre une semaine et et et 2 semaines
maxi ça dépend de du niveau d'intensité
et cetera quand il a fallu intervenir en
catastrophe à la demande d'État africain
on nait pas les moyens de
de projeter comme on dit c'estàdire de
moyens de
transport pour amener nos troupes et
quelques milliers d'homm c'était pas
voilà dans dans ces pays donc on
appelait alors les Allemands on appelait
les Russes et les Américains pour nous
donner moyens logistique de de pouvoir
projeter est-ce que vous pensez que
Macron il cauchemar de là il prend
conscience que notre dissuasion
nucléaire elle a plus que le nom il
conscience que nos forces bah c'est un
peu des forces des Cati est-ce que vous
pensez oui comment vous analysez le fait
qu'il s'agite ben parce que il était
hors
courseensite à la brillante dissolution
d'il y a d'un peu moins d'un an et donc
c'est très dur pour lui de ne pas
exister VO médiatiquement et tombe du
ciel l'affaire ukrainienne enfin Trump
et cetera et on voit il se
précipite pour
essayer de dire je suis le chef des
armées et cetera voilà alors que quand
vous liseez la Constitution française le
domaine réservé n'existe pas voyez la
politique militaire comme les affaires
étrangères sont aussi une compétence du
gouvernement et du Parlement c'est le
Parlement qui déclare la guerre c'est
pas le président de la République c'est
dans la Constitution française est-ce
qu'on est en guerre non pour le moment
non parce que vous avez pas été consulté
encore non non et et euh euh il n'y a
pas de force français projeté en Ukraine
dans les zones de combat on a des des
militaires en Roumanie le long de la
frontière hein on a des personnes qui
aident du vue logistique et cetera mais
on n pas de combattant français escalité
euh sur la ligne de front escalité ça
veut dire avec le petit drapeau bleu
blanc rouge sur lespaule en ououi oui
ouioui oui oui mais mais on a comme les
Allemands et et les autres
britanniques les Polonais qui aident
beaucoup les Polonais ont plus aidé
l'Ukraine que les Français vous avez
quoi comme téléphone portable
ah bah j'ai un téléphone qui est
complètement antique complètement
antique vous pouvez ouvrir une bière
avec euh non mais je peux vous montrer
si vous voulez la question c'est est-ce
qu'on vous a
briefé pour des questions d'ingérence
des question de logiciel ou de malware
malveillant si je vous dis Pegasus ça
vous fait penser à quoi non on n jamais
eu de de formation la matière
c'est-à-dire vous vous baladez en slip à
la plage sans crème solaire et sans Bob
non c'est pas ça mais si vous voulez je
ne suis pas dans une situation
aujourd'hui qui grand monde bon bah si
je vous dis que si les Russes veulent
s'intéresser à ce que vous allez
raconter sur l'Ukraine ils vous ont mis
un Pegasus sur votre téléphone ou Israël
ou les Britanniques ou quoi que ce soit
bah vous savez je c'est quoi un Pegasus
je sais pas je ne sais pas j'ai toujours
refusé si vous voulez d'avoir ses
smartphones et cetera ou toute la
journée d'ailleurs pour rire je demande
parfois à des amis montre-moi tes pouces
c'est pousces comme ça tu dois passer un
sacret parce que les pouss sont voilà ou
des gamins on VO les gamins voyz qui
font ça toute la journée quoi moi non je
n'ai jamais répondu à un sms ça vous dit
quelque chose les gens m'envoient des
SMS bon je que je lis quand quand j'ai
le temps parfois je voudrais je voudrais
que vous m'expliquiez les principes
d'intelligence artificielle oui ça
marche comment bah il y a plusieurs
formes d'intelligence artificielle le
début d'intelligence artificielle c'est
un un système de traitement des données
euh qui classait et cetera qui
permettait de retrouver et maintenant
c'est plus du tout ça intelligence
artificielle c'est beaucoup plus réactif
et c'est c'est j'ai j'ai testé un jour
c'était drôle on éit en plein débat sur
les retraites alors donc ça remonte à à
18 mois oui à peu près et 2 ans et avec
un ami on a demandé à à
à l'intelligence artificielle de nous
faire un discours en faveur de la
réforme des retraites et un autre
contre c'est sorti en 20 30 secondes
c'était pas exceptionnel he le discours
c'est quoi un billet de
programmation j'en sais rien moi je sais
pas je sais pas mais j'ai été frappé si
vous voulez de l'extrême vitesse et
quand j'ai lu ce qu'il avait préparé
pour ou contre euh bon ça méritait une
petite moyenne si vous voulez bon
c'était très voilà est-ce que vous avez
déjà été amené à voter une loi sur
l'intelligence artificielle moi pas
encore mais ça arrive là parce que il y
a y a il y a des textes communautaires
en cours de préparation qu' faudra
transposer en droit français donc ça ne
saurait
tarder mais mais chacun a a S thème vous
savez il y a des gens qui sont
passionnés par l'intelligenceicielle en
a d'autres qui sont passionnés par les
problèmes agricoles d'autres par les
problèmes sociaux enfin que sais-je il a
une grande université personne n a une
compétence universelle pour vous quel
est le plus grand risque que la France
va être obligée
de faire face ou ou quel plus grand
risque presse la
France bah je dirais il y a il y a
plusieurs risques Macron est un risque
non mais Macron c'est fini euh c'est
fini Macron dans 2 ans c'est fini bon
donc c'est pas vous êtes sûr de ça quand
quand il catapulte Ferrand il peut pas
se représenter est-ce que Ferrand il
peut il peut changer les choses
absolument pas c'est la Constitution
elle est claire
he un président ne peut pas se
représenter à l'issue de deux mandats
successifs il pourrait se représenter 5
ans plus tard un peu comme Poutine un
peu qui avait mis son ils ont fait un
switch avec son premier ministre voilà
ça c'est possible mais vous savez une
fois que vous avez quitté tous ceux qui
ont voulu revenir bon giscar a ramé
pendant 20 ans il est pas arrivé Sarkozi
a essayé il est pas
arrivé et donc Hollande ben il essaye
mais
voilà c'est pas simple unoncien
président les risques comment les
risques les plus alors les risqu les C
risques les grand risques pour moi c'est
le le le risque de l'état des finances
publiques françaises ça c'est pour moi
c'est c'est un risque voilà il y a le
risque
militaire il y a le le le risque de
l'explosion
sociale c'estàdire les gens étant
tellement exaspérés par les situation
qu'ils vivent qui se révolteent alors se
révolter c'est pas la solution parce
qu'une fois qu'on révolta je dis
toujours qu'est-ce qu'on fait maintenant
pas tout de se révolter c'est quelle
solution voilà c'est quoi la différence
entre une volte et une demi-volt un Volt
vol une Volt bah c'est unité de mesure
c'est c'est une figure aussi euh
d'équitation une révolte mais moi je
montais à c'est quoi la différence entre
une révolte et une révolution une
révolte à une révolution bah une révolte
c'est ponctuel une révolution c'est une
révolte qui s'est transformée en
révolution c'estàd qui change les
institutions donc l'instabilité sociale
c'est un risque et ensuite le dernier ah
le 4e un
4e un
5e qu'est-ce qu'il y a comme autre
risque le risque social le risque
économique risque
militaire ça après c'est des risques qui
me paraissent beaucoup plus faible le
risque
alimentaire non non le risque
énergétique non dans le cas de la France
non non on a pour des raisons
historiques on a quand même des moyens
importants on a vu quand quand quand la
Russie a coupé le gaz attendez nous on
avait je crois 20 % de gaz russe bon ben
on sa ils ont coupé le gaz oui ils ont
on était plus approvisionné la Russie
n'approvisionnait plus l'Allemagne la
France voilà très bien bon bon on s'en
est tiré très vite hein on s'est adressé
à qui euh aux Algériens hein qui ont
compensé le parti et puis surtout aux
Américains hein sous forme de GPL bah
oui on le paye mais comme tout voilà on
paye plus cher bah c'est ce qui est
assez étonnant c'est que c'est du gaz de
schiste interdit en France mais on
apporte du gaz de schiste même du
pétrole de schiste pour le le le pétrole
bon c'est différent parce que le pétrole
les approvisionnements sont son sont
plus diversifiés donc c'est vrai que
nous ce qu'on a subit comme tous les
pays européens et d'autres c'est une
très forte montée des prix le temps que
tout ça se règle qu'est-ce que vous
pouvez me dire sur un le pic énergétique
le pic de uber qu'est-ce que me dire sur
le marché de l'électricité européen
alors sur le pic le pic oil comme on
l'appelle c'était l'idée que les
ressources pétrolières sont limitées et
que donc il va y avoir un moment où
voilà la courbe va s'inverser donc c'est
le pic et puis après ça décroit alors
cette idée c'est comme toutes les idées
de Maltus est totalement inexacte
pourquoi parce que les réserves sont
fonction du prix pr plus le prix est
élevé plus les réserves augmentent
c'està dire parce queil y a un coûte
d'extraction donc si vous augmentez le
prix bah il y a des réserves non
exploitables qui deviennent exploitables
il y a deuxièmement l'évolution
technologique dans la technologie des
des puits de pétrole on a beaucoup
progressé sur ce qu'on appelle le taux
de récupération qui est combien en ce
moment je crois que d'après ce que vous
n avez dit le le patron de Total je
crois qu'ils arrivent alors ça dépend
les ZES 30 30 30 35 je crois hein ils
arrivent à 30 35 alors que il y a 50 ans
on était pédiblement à 10 15 Z et donc
c'est pour ça
que même en pétrole il y a pas de pénuie
et et en matière de gaz alors là il y a
des ressources considérables considérabl
en matière d'uranium bah l'uranium il
est il est heureusement assez bien
réparti parce qu'on on parle que des
mines uranium d'uranium africaine mais
prenez au Canada il y a des très très
grandes carrièr de de minerais d'uranium
voire dans d'autres endroits
donc la pénurie ne peut-être que
temporaire parce que par les hasards de
la géologie l'uranium n'est pas
concentré dans un seul endroit du monde
dans quelle concentration l'uranium au
Canada comment quelle concentration en
uranium au Canada les mines d'uranium
c'est une grosse concentration une
petite concentra qu'est-ce que va faire
vouz dire la part de de l'uranium
canadien dans nos approvisionnems oui si
vous voulez ou la part la part de de de
comment expliquer ça d'une façon simple
la partis je crois me souvenir c'est 15
20 % je crois déjà d'uranium canadien au
moins voyez je crois me souvenir mais le
monde entier est en train de se se
diriger vers l'augmentation de la
production de réacteur
oui enfin c'est est-ce que vous avez vu
autant de mines sous ouvrir en fonction
des décisions politiques mondiales non
mais s'il y a une tension sur
l'approvisionnement en uranium ça prend
du temps parce que cont une centrale
nucléaire ça se fait pas en 6 mois he ça
ça se fait en combien de temps et ben
quand c'est mis amené 7 ans et le Pr de
flamandville on a mis 20 ans voilà donc
quelque part entre 7 et 20 allez prenez
une dizaine d'années donc on a le temps
quand même d'augmenter la production des
carrières existances ou d'en trouver de
de y compris d'ailleurs en France
puisque il y a des recherches du bureau
de recherche géologique et minre le BRGM
pour voir si on pouvait
pas ouvrir des des des mines d'uranium
je crois qu'elles sont enfin on a
l'uranium en France mais la densité fait
que les coûts d'extraction sont plus
élevés voilà en terme de densité voilà
mais le problème c'est à partir de quand
le ça devient exploitable ça c'est un
problème du prix du kilo d'uranium
comment ça se fait que le marché de
l'électricité est indexé sur le prix du
gaz alors
était il était bah c'était assez logique
à l'époque quand on avait voulu faire le
marché commun l'électricité s'est posé
la question mais c'est un marché commun
on va avoir un prix unique et pourquoi
est-ce qu'on a pris le gaz parce que le
gaz les centrales à gaz faisaient
l'équilibre entre l'offre et la demande
puisquon peut les déclencher très très
vite et donc c'était logique où c'est
pas devenu c'est à partir du moment où
il y a eu l'arrêt des livraisons de gaz
russes et donc les les les Français ont
rêvé d'obtenir ce qu' on obtenu les
Portugais les Espagnols qui ont réussi à
se déconnecter mais ils ont pu se
déconnecté parce que ça ne perturbait
pas l'équilibre nous notre problème
c'est qu'on est au milieu et en plus on
approvisionne euh avec nos 15 % exportés
de d'électricité on on on alimente pas
que la Belgique on exporte aussi
beaucoup vers l'Allemagne or si on
arrêtait si vous c'est qu'on disait on
se replie onorte plus d'électricité le
temps que tout ça se et ben on mettait
une pagaille dans dans dans le système
allemand et donc c'est pour ça qu'il y a
eu des grandes discussions qui ont duré
duré duré duré pour essayer de trouvver
bon alors ça finit par être trouvé mais
ça a mis des moins et des moins et des
mois qu'est-ce que vous pouvez me dire
alors quand quand quand j'ai eu votre
assistant au
téléphone il m'a dit que que vous étiez
planté sur les questions de flux
migratoire de grands remplacement suis
planté oui c'estd vous avez fait vous
avez reçu des mails parce qu'il y a des
gens qui ne comprenaient pas que vous
puissiez répondre ça que vous ne voyez
pas leur quotidien et donc est-ce que
vous avez travaillé les réponses
concernant la préoccupation mais moi
j'ai toujours eu une position très
simple pourquoi il y a des flux
migratoires d'où viennent ces flux
migratoires c'est très simple il y a
deux problèmes il y a le problème
démographique européen
puisque euh à part la France et encore
de de justesse en 2024 et au rythme
actuel tout le monde un nombre de décès
supérieur au nombre de berceaux donc
comment gérer c'est le problème qu'on
les Chinois les Japonais les Coréens
comment gérer un un espace comme
l'espace européen euh dans cette
situation là c'est pour ça qu'on voit le
patronat pousse à mort en disant mais
non il faut autoriser donc le c'est tout
le problème de l'immigration choisi bon
et ça c'est le premier problème le
deuxème problème c'est que quand vous
voyez la pagaille en
afriquein et au Moyen-Orient mais déjà
en Afrique si vous voulez entre
l'éritrée l'Éthiopie le Soudan c'est
atroce ce qui se passe là-bas ça
n'intéresse personne mais enfin c'est
des centaines de milliers de gens qui
sont affamés et et je dis toujours si
vous étiez
soudanais malien qu'est-ce que vous
faites il y a pas d'espoir pour vous un
jour je suis Allis au foyer de l'enfance
de de de de Chalon en Champagne et puis
j'ai discuté avec les mineurs qui étai
pour la plupart d'ailleurs majeurs enfin
les meilleurs dit non accompagnés bon
pour voir quelles étaient leur
motivations bah c'était tous la même
chose c'est la misère hein la guerre
civile
ouais
donc une politique intelligente et
coordonnée de l'Union européenne ça
serait de dire à ses pays d'origine on
est prêt à vous aider pour vous
développer mais la contrepartie c'est
tous vos ressortissant qui sont pris en
Europe dans une situation régulière on
vous les réexpédie et vous les reprenez
sinon on interromp
l'aide voyez ça ça sera une politique
intelligente et de faire une immigration
choisie parce qu'on a besoin je dis
toujours à ceux qui disent immigration
zéro je dis ok bon tu fréquentes les
hôpitaux de temps en temps alors on va
fermer des services entiers dans les
hôpitaux
voilà qui qui
refuse de de telle et telle tâche c'est
nos nationaux je ve dire qui ramasse les
poubelles je veux dire donc on voit bien
et en plus avec un déclin démographique
un peu partout la France était une
exception je suis pas sûr qu'elle va le
rester longtemps on a besoin d'une
immigration choisie voilà moi ma
position alors j'ai dit ça alors alors
j'ai eu une lettre avant en disant mais
vous ne sortez jamais de chez vous enfin
voyez vous rendez pas compte il habitait
à Lyon la personne qui m'a écrit et lu
dit j'ai ramené mon fils à la gare à
lyonprache et ben il y avait des
étrangers qui étaient là à fé et cetera
on est plus chez nous quoi voilà c'est
pas normal et cetera voilà ce que je lui
ai
répondu quand on voit que
la notre grand leader charismatique
Emmanuel Macron
notre grand timonniier veut réarmer la
démographie mais il y a pas de pédiatre
il y a de moins en moins d'hôpitaux
quand on va aux urgences faut attendre
24 heures sur un brancard il y a pas de
prof il y a pas de garderie mais la la
vraie question quand je discute avec des
jeunes femmes he est-ce qu'elles veulent
fonder une famille est-ce qu'elles
veulent avoir des enfants bon vous avez
maintenant une part des jeunes filles y
compris dans ma propre famille de mes
nièes j'ai h niè on discute de ça il y
en a qui ont des enfants et il y en a
d'autres il y en a une qui me dit moi je
veux pas d'enfant et je dis pourquoi tu
veux pas d'enfant elle me dit parce que
tu comprends ça nuit à ma liberté et
cetera bon alors je respecter les les
les les les goûts de de de chacun mais
on voit bien que vous avez des jeunes
filles qui ne veulent plus d'enfant
alors les les arguments sont très divers
1 c'est irresponsable de mettre au monde
des enfants dans ce monde tel qu'il est
bon c'est quoi comensible ah non mais
moi je respecte les choix de chacun hein
je dis simplement vous avez des enfants
non je suis un vieux célibataire vous
avez des chats ah non vous avez pas de
chat non j'ai pas de chat j'ai pas de
Ch j'ai des vux et niè j'en ai 10 voilà
donc pour revenir à à notre affaire bon
c'est la première raison vous avez sur
les grands centres urbains aussi le
problème du coup du logement ils disent
mais moi je voulais avoir deux enfants
j'en ai qu'un puisqueen moyenne les
femmes disent qu'elles ont eu un enfant
de moins que ce qu'elles souhaitaient et
quand on leur dit mais pourquoi bah les
contraintes dans un petit appartement
après il faut élever les enfants et
cetera mais si vous voulez on avait une
politique démographique qui a été mise
en œuvre à la Libération d'ailleurs
enfin d la libération en fait avant elle
a été mis en œuvre en fait en 38 39 le
code de la famille il est de 38 ou de 39
c'est la la fin de la 3è République he
qui char je peux vous couper une seconde
oui je peux gratter combien de minutes
parce que je sais que vous êtes vieux et
que vous devez vous coucher tôt
euh il est 20h13 20h14 et je devais
terminer je devais vous lâcher à 20h15
oui mais il y avait un droit de de rap
de 10 minutes un quart d'heure ou mais
mais pas
plus vous couchez à quelle heure moi je
me couche en principe à 23h30 et je me
lève à 6h30 revenons sur la politique de
natalité fissa oui et donc les
motivations des jeunes filles c'est
quand même les jeunes filles qui
décident d'avoir des enfants ou pas des
enfants je dis pas que le géniteur comme
on les appelle maintenant n'ont pas un
rôle c'est quand même plus fac c'est
parents a ou parB ah moi je suis vous
savez je suis très écologique en amour
voyez je je je pense que nous avons fait
nous avons été fait hommes et femmes
pour nous aimer voilà et pour élever
ensemble les enfants et et ceux qui
élèvent tout seul surtout des femmes
d'ailleurs mais aussi moi j'ai des amis
qui sont devenus veuves leur épouse est
morte voyez ils ont élevé tout seul des
enfants c'est quand même pas simple hein
donc et puis pour les enfants d'avoir
une mère et un père c'est bon pour leur
développement leur épanouissement
voilà il y a pas de pédiatre il y a pas
de prof les hôpitaux qui se cassent la
gueule le service public qui se cassent
la gueule ça motive pas trop pour faire
des dire qu'il y a pas de prof hein bah
il y a pas de prof non non le problème
c'est le recrutement des professeurs et
vous avez vu combien vouz payer c'est
oui mais c'est une politique si vous
voulez quand vous comparez la
rémunération des professeurs allemands
et des professeurs français il y a un
écart qui s'est beaucoup ACC cru en 40
ans pourquoi on veut pas dire la vérité
c'est que au lieu de payer correctement
euh nos professeurs et bien on les a
payé en réduisant en réduisant le nombre
d'heures travaillé et le nombre de jours
travaillés moi j'ose plus le dire quand
j'étais jeune
euh en primaire savez-vous combien on
avait d'heures
d'enseignement par semaine
30h et actuellement les enfants
travaillent 32 33 semaines par an nous
on travaillait encore un peu plus et et
et ces 30 heures nous on les faisait
lundi mardi mercredi jeudi c'était les
vacances vendredi samedi matin et
après-midi après on a supprimé le samedi
matin et donc on a décalé du jeudi au
mercredi ce qui était logique qu'on
faisait plus de 4 jours donc si vous
voulez si on veut réévaluer le le le le
le le salaire des enseignants je prends
l'exemple du primaire on est tombé à à
24 he hein on était à 30 et ben moi je
serais pour qu'on remonte
progressivement de de 24 à 30h et avec
majoration à du concurrence de la
rémunération
ouais la dissuasion nucléaire on la
partage bah on peut pas de Gaulle de ce
point de vue là avait raison en disant
il y en a qu'un qui appuie sur le
bouton donc si vous voulez qu'elle soit
efficace il faut qu'on sache qu'à tout
moment le chef de l'État puisque dans
l'organisation française c'est le chef
de l'État c'est pas le premier ministre
qui peut engager l'arbre nucléaire bon
d' il y a toujours quelqu'un à côté de
lui avec la ballette machin et cetera
bon et et donc ça ne se partage pas ça
veut pas dire que on ne peut pas
utiliser nos armes nucléaires pour
protéger notamment les les les Allemands
les
Polonais le bénéuxe pourquoi protéger
les Allemands alors qu'ils ont essayer
de torpiller notre industrie nucléaire
oui mais tout ça a
changé non non mais on leur
pardonneis mais c'est pas un problème de
pardon c'est de se tourner vers l'avenir
et de dire où est l'intérêt des uns et
des autres l'intérêt des uns et des
autres c'est d'être solidaire et de se
protéger les uns les autres et si les
armes nucléaires françaises voire
britanniques peuvent être utilisé euh
pour protéger les Britanniques c'est un
peu compliqué l' nucléaire britannique
elle est pas britannique elle est
américaine alors alors le problème c'est
euh jusqu'où va l'indépendance
britannique en matière d'engagement des
tridentss puisque c'est des tridant
l'émicile les tridants nous nous avons
une indépendance qu'on a payé cher hein
puisque quand on compare les budgets
militaires grosso modo la force
nucléaire c'est 25 % du budget de la
défense 25 % donc quand on compare on
devrait sortir le nucléaire pour
comparer par rapport aux
autres comment ça va se terminer cette
guerre on va finir sur un risau de fer
bien dur bien bien dur on va finir par
se [__] sur la figure on va finir par
essayer de mettre des colombes on va
essayer de reconstruire une diplomatie
on va essayer de se mettre des analyses
qui puissent anticiper les guerres pour
éviter qu'on arrive a des situations
pareilles on fait quoi c'est bien
difficile à dire ouis je pense que les
guerres finissent toujours et elles
finissent toujoursilà la prochaine on se
battra avec des des cailloux et des
bâtons hein et là on on attaque la 4e
année si vous prenez la comparaison de
141 ou de 39 45 en 17 hein euh là on a
vu les négociations secrète ou plus
moins secrète pour essayer de sortir de
ce bourbier dans lequel s'était mis
l'Europe et qui a amené à une
catastrophe pour l'ensemble des
Européens par parenthèse et en 39 45 on
est en 43 en 43 les carottes sont cuites
hein voilà alors que là les carotes ne
sont pas cuites et est-ce
que Monsieur Poutine peut continuer
encore très longtemps à à soutenir son
effort de guerre
ouais d'après les sondages qui sont fait
qui sont publiés dans la presse il est
encore soutenu hein par presque 2/3 des
Russes pourquoi euh
parce que ce garçon il exploite le
nationalisme grand russe comme on disait
au 19e siècle c'est-à-dire le
nationalisme la Grande
Russie facteur de civilisation voyez
quand il prend ses ses discours en
disant vous avez déjà été en Russie oui
oui deux fois oui combien de temps je
suis allé deux fois un mois vous AZ où
ça à Saint-Pétersbourg et à Moscou non
non pas à
leningr Saint-Pétersbourg oui maintenant
un un cadre de voyage personnel non non
oui oui oui oui oui je voulais un peu
découvrir la Russie mais je suis pas
allé en Sibérie quelle année
euh il y a
maintenant 10 et 15 ans c'est-à-dire
après l'effondrement de 99 voilà et j'ai
été frappé par la tristesse j'ai trouvé
ça très triste voyez le soir quand vous
voyez l'alcoolisme c'est terrible
terrible et et plus vous allez vers
l'ouest il y a plus d'enfants il y a
plus d'enfants j'avais un guide elle
était enseignante dans le primaire elle
gagnait plus pendant les 2 mois d'été
que pendant les 10 mois où elle était
enseignante et alors je invité à
déjeuner alors au début elle voulait pas
et puis elle a fini par accepter et elle
m'a dit qu'elle était son salaire coquin
non non pas du tout pas du tout non non
mais mais j'aime bien moi discuter avec
les gens et en fait son salaire
mensuel c'était ce que coûtait le
restaurant dans lequel j'avais invité à
déjeuner et donc voyez elle trouvait que
voilà quelle année ça et ben ça c'était
il y a 10 ans voilà et des conditions
rudes de de de de vie dure très
espérance de vie 54 ans oui mais c'est
l'alcoolisme quand vous voyez le matin
les bouteilles de de volka sur les
trottoir à Moscou à Saint-Pétersbourg
partout vous dites mais bon sang et puis
alors les les hommes et les femmesin et
beaucoup de femmes me disent on en a
marre des des hommes russes parce que
quand un homme est bourré qu'est-ce
qu'il fait il tape pas plus compliqué
que ça donc certaines d'entre elles moi
j'en ai dans ma circonscription elles
ont essayé de se sauver elles se sont
trouvé un sympathique agriculteur elles
ont une vie qui n'a rien à voir de temps
en temps fait venir leurs sœur alors les
sœurs c'est c'est c'est voyez on voit le
le les conditions de vie dures dur dur
dur
on arrive à la fin parce qu'il faut que
je vous lâche vous avez de la route je
voudrais trois livres à conseiller à
notre communauté qui ont été importants
pour vous B le le premier c'est les
bouquins d'Alexis toville alors celui le
plus connu de la démocratie en Amérique
mais les deux autres qui sont moins
connus qui
sont la celui sur la révolution dans
lequel il il montre que au fond la
révolution n'a fait qu'accélérer le
mouvement de centralisme de la royauté
française qui est très intéressant du
point de vue
sociologique et puis son troisème
bouquin bon c'est ses souvenirs vous
savez de cette période où il a été un
éphémère ministre bon voilà et mais
c'est très intéressant parce qu'il
explique comment lui qui était royaliste
devient républicain voilà et et il
explique d'une façon très simple en
disant quelle est l'essentiel c'est pas
la forme politique d'une organisation
politique c'est les libertés voilà la
défense des libertés pour chacun ça
c'est le premier après il y a un auteur
que j'aime beaucoup qui est honoré de
Balsac voilà et la comédie ubaine ouais
ou c'est je trouve ça la description si
vous voulez des caractères euh de de
l'âme humaine
ou l'âme humaine
euh moi j'ai jamais cru que l'espèce
humaine était pé de bisnounours hein
voilà donc faut être prudent machin il y
a de tout dans l'espèce hum il y a des
gens formidables il y a des gens euh
allez on va dire gentiment pas très
recommandabl quoi voilà des sociopathes
comment des
sociopathes pourquoi vous dites les
sociopathes et puis un un un le livre de
Bruno le ma non non non c'est pas c'est
pas non Bruno Levert je je le laisse à
ses romans à l'UD de rose ou à ses
essais romans c'est ça m'intéresse pas
du tout et pu d contre lui ah non mais
moi je l'appelle monsieur mil milliard
l'homme qui valait 1000 milliards
l'homme qui valait 1000 milliards oui en
célèbre film voyez il est arrivé il y
avait 2300 Milliards de dettes publ il
est reparti il y en avait 3300 il vous
explique oui mais il y a eu c'est vrai
la crise 2008 la crise8 2008 le covid et
cetera mais lui-même dit que ça ça
explique 200 50 milliards pour faire ça
le
quart et je dis souvent en riant je
voudrais être son
élève en Suisse ça serait très drôle où
il apprend probablement à ses élèves ce
qu'il aurait dû faire pour
pil il n pasindit d'avoir un peu
d'humour en la matière
voilà et voilà donc restons sérieux un
trè bouquin alors un 3è bouquin
vient comme
ça et ben ça vous étonner Tintin les
algomes Tintin au Congo non au Congo
mais vous savez qu'il y a plusieurs
versions de Tintin au
Congo j'ai acheté un bouquin très
intéressant du grande spécialiste de
Tintin et sur l'analyse des personnages
et de chacun de ses albums moi j'ai
décou Tintin gamin moi c'était un héros
pour moi Tintin voyez l'homme juste qui
redressait les torts voilà qui s'en
sortait toujours la colonisation tout ça
voilà mais mais quand vous regardez les
les les différentes albums par exemple
Le Lotus bleu moi j'avais pas vu que
c'est violemment anti-japonais puisqu'il
soutenait des nationalistes chinois
voyez Tintin au Tibet
Chang Tang je savais pas que Tang avait
existé
ah il av des relations avec RG bon voilà
et et et Tintin au Congo alors il y a eu
plusieurs éditions la première c'est
vraiment le le colonialisme dans toute
son horreur quoi je veux dire tout le
monde il est beau les Africains sont des
sous-développés voilà avec un os enfin
voyez ouis enfin des caricatures voilà
mais euh il y a d'autres Objectif Lune
c'est formidable Objectif Lune voilà là
il y a pas d'interprète
politico quand on sait en plus son passé
de rexiste puis sa qu' était
rexistein de l'extrême droite belge
voilà et que il a fallu qu'il se fasse
oublier à la Libération en Belgique
voilà puis après il est revenu voilà et
puis il a évolué comme beaucoup voilà
Gaston la gaff
oui Gaston la gaff je regardé ça quand
j'étais plus jeune bon mais Gaston la
gaff c'est pas trop bon truc est-ce que
vous avez un conseil pour les jeunes
générations
une bouteille à la mer quelque chose
d'impérissable qui restera sur Internet
qui se
fera crollé par de l'intelligence
artificielle peut-être un jour
non le le faire un message c'est le
contenu d'un message qu'on mettrait dans
conseil pour les jeunes générations oui
et ben de garder l'espoir toujours
toujours voyez croyant vous avez un ami
un ami imaginaire vous croyez en Dieu
oui je suis croyant oui oui je crois en
Jésus-Christ pour être précis oui et et
l'espérance
voyez moi j'ai connu des gens qui ont
connu les camps de
concentration je leur disais toujours
comment as-tu pu
survivre alors c'est très différent
j'avais un collègue de la Cour des
comptes bien il est mort maintenant il
m'avait dit son â oui il m'avait dit moi
j'ai tenu parce que je voulais me venger
j'avais une obsession quand on sera
libéré je vais tuer un enfant allemand
non mais voyez tellement il étai j'ai
deux amis qui sont morts centenaires
toutes les deux qui mon vbrook l'une me
dit moi j'ai tenu parce que j'avais un
fils qui avait 1 an quand j'étais
arrêté et l'autre elle était célibataire
mais elle était très résistant était
fils de paysanyz elle avait été élevée à
la dur dans les fermes si vous voulez et
donc et puis elles étaient toutes les
deux relativement petites moi j'avais un
oncle qui était très grand il a laissé
sa
peau il se prenait les il est mort
là-bas mon grand-père aussi et lui il a
toujours tenu tête au
SS toujours et il a cru à la victoire
bien avant 42 c'està dire 42 début 43 le
point de retournement de la guerre et un
jour un de ses cousins arrive et lui dit
Léo il s'appelait Léonel Léo il lui dit
les HES ont gagné c'est
fini dans la bibliothèque il a pris
rabelet qu'est-ce qu'il a pris c'est
rabelet la guerre de conquête il dit
voilà ce qui va arriver
àclair et dans son
camp euh il faisait la carte de l'Europe
et il expliqu aux autres prisonniers on
gagnera voilà ils sont là ils sont ils
sont perdus ils sont foutus voilà mais h
là il est mort en
mars 45 un mois avant la libération du
camp quant à ma grand-mère elle était à
Raven Brook
elle elle est morte en
janvier 45
mais elle était très fragile et puis
elle avait déjà un certain âge elle
avait près de 60 ans et vous savez les
gens âgés euh il tenaient pas longtemps
c'est plutôt les jeunes et surtout ceux
qui étaient en commando parce que dans
les commando ils étaient moins mal nourr
et comme ils avaient besoin d'eux comme
main d'œuvre il tapaient moins dessus
que dans le camp d'ailleurs à RB ceux
qui sont restés au camp 2 tiers sont
morts dans les commandau l'inverse
ouais mais ma grand-mère est resté dans
le toujours garder espoir
toujours Charles de courourson merci
[Musique]